[Musique]
chers amis bienvenue commencé comme
toujours je reçois des invités qui font
partie de l'histoire mondiale
à cette occasion je reçois une véritable
référence de la question du droit de
chacun à être humain à une alimentation
je veux parler de jean ziegler
rapporteur spécial des nations unies sur
le droit à l'alimentation de 2000 à 2008
actuel vice-président du comité
consultatif des droits de l'homme des
nations unies
merci beaucoup aux gens d'avoir accepté
mon invitation merci de l'invitation
c'est un grand honneur de discuter avec
où la fao concise est là
la fao l'organisation des nations unies
pour l'alimentation et l'agriculture qui
considère que la planète pourrait
alimenter le double de la population
mondiale actuelle
comment expliquer comment expliquer
qu'avec de telles capacités des gens
meurent de faim vous l'avez dit un
enfant qui meurt de faim est un enfant
assassiné et une ligne à senna vous
savez tout à fait récent le scandale de
notre temps le principalement le
principe à scandales longtemps c'est la
mort de 1000 et 2000 et 2002 personne de
la fin sur une planète quitter votre
richesse
vous avez cité le volt food report la
fao qui est que personne ne conteste qui
donne des chiffres des victimes tous les
to les années en avril 2
foot du port de l'info qui dit que tous
les cinq secondes l'année dernière tous
les cinq secondes un enfant de 10 ans
est mort de faim ou de ses suites
immédiates ou les 5 secondes et le même
woerth foutry port qui tourne le chiffre
des victimes dit que lui que
l'agriculture mondiale telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui temps sur le développement
actuel pour les nourrir sans problème de
1200 calories individus adultes un jour
sans problème 12 milliard d'êtres
humains
nous sommes 7 8 3 donc presque le double
de l'humanité si l'accès à la nourriture
était garanti pour été nourries
normalement je prends un autre chiffre
vous pour vous montrez vous le savez que
chaque an à peu près 70 millions de
personnes quittent la planète meurs
meurs 70 millions de personnes pour des
raisons multiples et les caire les
maladies et c2c 60 millions de personnes
qui meurent par an 14 8 rue 8 millions
14,8 millions meurent de faim ou de ses
suites immédiates
ça veut dire que la fin aujourd'hui sur
une planète qui déborde richesse est
toujours la première cause de mortalité
sur cette année alors comment expliquer
ce paradoxe hayes alors c'est une
aberration
voilà alors là c'est une question
centrale mais mais difficile à répondre
très rapidement votre jeu pomme on
élaborait en énoncer quelques mécanismes
qui sont responsables du massacre de la
faim dans le monde
aujourd'hui où nous parlons d'une part
bien sûr c'est le surendettement des
pays du tiers-monde des pays du sud sur
des porcs la tête
la souveraine la dette publique était de
plus de 2
2100 milliards de 1100 milliards au 31
décembre dernier donc dette écrasante
pour la plupart des pays ce qui fait que
la productivité agricole dans les pays
agricole est souvent les pays du tiers
monde sont des pays agricole est très
très basse je prends un exemple dans les
sept pays du sahel dont kossuth pays qui
sont frontaliers du sud du sahara
en période normale quand ya pas de
guerre pas de sécheresse pas de criquets
pas de catastrophe qu'elle comptait en
temps normal à l'hectare dont 600 à 700
kg de ville la fête de céréales holliger
nomadio pour qu'il te fasse de cet open
c'est 600 700 kg et les années normaux
normal saura relation sécheraient
souvent critiqué souvent des aubades bus
une belle qu'en bretagne en lombardie
ailleurs en europe ces dix mille kilos
par hectare de terrain
timmy kg pas exceptionnel non pas parce
que pays africain tellement moins
compétents plus paresseux - travailleurs
que le paysan italiens français belges
ou allemandes
non mais parce que le paysan suisse
français allemands à des semences
sélectionnées à de la traction à de
l'assurance de l'irrigation à l'accès au
marché de cet état qui n'existe pas dans
ce pays comme le niger le mali ou le
bénin où l'état surendetté ne peut
investir rien du tout dans le dans
l'agriculture
la deuxième raison c'est le dumping
agricole de l'union européenne où il
savait que l'union européenne et verse
ses surplus agricoles qui sont massifs
sur les marchés africains ces démarches
implication prends un exemple le marché
en afrique occidentale
dakar sénégal en afrique occidentale le
marché le plus coloré le plus brillant
le plus vivant c'est le marché de la
santa chaos coeur même de takhar a
l'ascendant la santé car vous pouvez
acheter des oranges espagnol des pommes
de terre danois d'été pour les allemands
et se traitant à bouaké ou au tiers du
prix du poulet des avaient été produits
agricoles c
des mangues etc des produits agricoles
sénégalaises sénégalais et quelques
kilomètres plus loin sur le continent de
la presqu'île vous avez pays s'envole of
pan balaou enfin le paysan s'est décalé
qui se crèvent tout seul par jour avec
sa femme et son ses enfants sous ce
soleil de plomb et qui n'a pas la
moindre chance pas la moindre chance
d'arriver à un niveau un besoin vital
amie rita la cause du dumping agricole
pratiqué par l'union européenne sur les
marchés sur les marchés africains c'est
la deuxième raison la troisième raison
c'est la base c'est le vol de terre
l'année dernière 41 millions d'hectares
ont passé entre les mains de te la fais
pas de l'afrique touche de l'afrique au
sud du sahara la france son oncle entre
le sahara et le cap sont passés entre
les mains des agences de banques trop
grandes sociétés financières
multinationales qui rachète qui rachète
était expulsé pays sans plantes des
roses des pommes de t5 l'une des
céréales etc pour l'exportation pour
l'exportation en arabie séoudite nouveau
au japon en europe et settat et les pays
ça expulsés finissent dans les
bidonvilles de la côte atlantique où les
cordes les rats où il ya la prostitution
enfantine le chômage permanent pour les
hommes la destruction des familles
aujourd'hui la fin on sait et plus
personne n'ose dire le compte y est la
fin est faite demain dans la suite de
structures temporaires et aux pressions
de cet ordre cannibale du monde sous
l'eau qu'est ce cela que nous vivons que
le grand capital a imposé à la planète
nous vivons sous ses ordres cannibale du
monde pour la raison très simple
selon l'annuaire la banque mondiale
pour prendre un exemple la nuit et de la
banque mondiale l'année dernière les 500
plus grandes sociétés transcontinentales
privé tous secteurs confondus
industriebank que celui-ci des 500 plus
grandes sociétés transcontinentales
privés ont contrôlé 52,9 % du produit
mondial brut c'est-à-dire 52,9 % de
toutes les richesses produites en une
année sur la planète et cette inégalité
toute puissance d'un côté destruction
dans la misère
enfin dans l'eau polluée négation des
droits élémentaires à l'existence qui
augmente abouti à ce que j'appelle à
nortel cannibale du monde à nortel
cannibale du monde puisqu'il est très
très riches se nourrissent du sang de la
chair des très pauvres
je pourrais rétorqué que ce que vous
proposez est une sorte de jeu à somme
nulle où ce que l'un gagné perdu par
d'autres mais il n'est pas nécessaire
qu'il en soit ainsi
un capitalisme libéral dirais que non ce
sont des entrepreneurs qui génère de la
richesse ils ont amélioré la vie de
beaucoup de gens ainsi que leurs propres
via merulana celui non bon ça c'est la
vieille théorie adam smith et de ricardo
de david ricardo au xviiie siècle le tri
cld aoun effect or c'est une erreur
totale
l'histoire a montré que le télé que dans
les faits ça n'existe pas parce que pour
les oligarques depuis longtemps l'argent
n'a plus rien à voir avec la valeur
d'usagé avec la valeur d'usagé ça plus
rien à rolle cloud usage
l'argent est un moyen de pouvoir est
plus riche que l'autre des personnes que
bennett est plus riche que l'autre
l'argent est
une arme est une arme n'a pas tu n'y a
pas de limite à l'accumulation puisqu'il
ya plus de rapport quelconque avec une
valeur d' usage de l'argent et donc les
oligarques deviennent toujours plus
riche la plus value de leur production
qui augmentent est absorbée est
monopolisée exclusivement par eux et la
multitude de ceux qui vivent dans la
misère et dans l'ombre augmentent ils
deviennent les pauvres rapidement plus
pauvres les riches rapidement plus
riches ces l'heure et c'est ça
qu'il faut encore une fois c'est pour ça
que cette offre est cannibale du monde
même si teva création par exemple
jusqu'à 200 la fin a reculé et la cua
elles augmentent de nouveau maintenant
ils augmentent nouveau parce qu'il ya
deux types fin je suis je suis je
reviens à viens te dire la fin
conjoncturelle et la fin structurelle la
fin conjoncturel c'est la fin c'est des
familles c'est visible c'est visible
quand une guerre commence au yémen au
sud-soudan maintenant c'est la fin
conjoncture s et des familles où tout à
coup il est que lui s'effondre à cosnac
est une société fondée il ya la famille
seul afin que j'oserais mais la plupart
des victimes de la faim sont victimes de
la faim structurelles structurel c'est à
dire la fin implicite temps les forces
insuffisamment développée depuis
l'économiste une et que lui la phase
structurelle qui est qui est implicite
dans le sous développement de l'économie
les communes des colis de produits
passés ne distribue pas c'est qui tient
je le répète eu massacre de l'assassinât
parce que il n'ya aucune quelconque
fatalité effet de main d'homme
aujourd'hui un homme sur sept succès
planète et ce qui nous sépare des
victimes c'est uniquement le hasard de
la naissance
ça pourrait être vous ça pourrait être
moi
mon fils mon enfant qui a le no maki à
le coacher cordes tout si tous ces
maladies effroyable de la faim qui
détruisent le visage qui détruisent le
corps ils sont assassinés
ils sont assassinés parce que ils sont
du produit par des structures mises en
place par les puissantes par les
puissants par les oligarques pas
désobligeants lequel est brisé le bras
de ces oligarques pas seuls les peuples
peuvent le faire comment ça va se faire
on ne sait pas mais je suis certain le
cartel est formidable mouvement lille et
gilet jaune en france
formidable la jeunesse irakienne
la jeunesse libanaise l'algérie le chili
c'est extraordinaire ces mouvements
populaires qui viennent de nulle part et
qui sont puissants et qui met en
question qui compte est radicalement les
pouvoirs en place du port en place
[Musique]
claro professeur le quai il est clair
professeur que depuis le 20e siècle
depuis l'après guerre
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
l'âme la pauvreté et la faim ne sont
plus le fruit du manque de ressources de
questions naturelles sécheresses
inondations ou etc mais de système
pervers un appel à témoins de ce fait il
est incompréhensible qu avec toutes les
capacités en notre possession que chaque
être humain puisse s'alimenter de façon
adéquate mais il y ait des gens qui
meurent de faim et vivent dans une
pauvreté extrême
donc le problème n'est pas un problème
technique
c'est un problème lié à un système
pervers comme vous l'avez dit je parle
de l'oligarchie et du capitalisme sans
limite et enrichie ces oligarchies
vous avez été très critique envers les
biocarburants ou agrocarburants
car il y aurait un effet d'exclusion
entre le fait de semer pour le carburant
et de semer pour l'alimentation
il ne devrait pas en être ainsi avec la
capacité agricole qui est la nôtre il y
a assez de ressources pour
l'alimentation et pour les biocarburants
et les biocarburants sont beaucoup plus
respectueux de l'environnement ils sont
renouvelables ce qui est un point très
important vous considérez donc qu'il
n'est pas correct de continuer à
développer les deux carburants mais non
mais c'est compliqué hein là aussi à une
ya beaucoup beaucoup de malentendus et
des contre offensives étaient entre
saintes et nationaux c'est vrai il ya un
argument courant qui dit les
biocombustibles bioéthanol au biodiesel
soudain gouvernement nous développions
cela rien nous pensions que c'était une
solution non on a au moins une
atténuation des différents problèmes
environnementaux ou liées aux
combustibles fossiles
info c'est bon les biocombustibles
remplace l'énergie fossile
c'est faux c'est l'énergie fossile
détruit de climat co2 etc tant qu'on
peut l'être pour les bio pour le
bioéthanol pour le biodiesel remplaçant
l'énergie fossile
à première vue c'est raisonnable en dise
ça sauve le climat premier lui
mais si on le regarde plus près c'est
pas vrai le programme obama je prends
l'exemple où les où les états unis ont
produit le plus de bio éthanol durant le
deuxième mandat d'obama
les etats-unis ont brûlé le tiers de
leurs récoltes de maïs 138 millions de
tonnes 138 millions de tonnes pour faits
de biocombustibles fait de
biocombustibles et la théorie d'obama
était la suivante c'était de dire les
états unis utilisent c'est la plus
grande est sa plus grande puissance
industrielle du monde les états unis
utilisent tous les jours vingt millions
de barils
20 millions de barils de ses 20 millions
de barils 12 seulement sont produits
entre alaska et le texas tombe dans le
pays même et le reste est importé est
importé est importée due
le pétrole donc le est importé de région
très dangereuse le moyen-orient abysses
et le thé l'état du niger etc qui force
des états unis de maintenir des carnets
sont militaires au moyen-orient de mener
des guerres etc pour s'assurer de ces
sources pétrolières de ces super taulier
de financer israël comme jandal du monde
afin comme personnel de remercier les
états unis dans la région et obama
tissés pour réduire l'importation
pétrolières qui nous force à ces
investissements militaires et de
s'intéresser et bien il faut augmenter
les agrocarburants faut augmenter les
agrocarburants qui ferait que
finalement on ne doit plus importer du
pétrole bilbo et il est allé dans cette
direction maintenant c'est différent
parce qu'il le fera qu il ya le problème
du schiste etc
les états unis la situation péter
reliera complétant les états unis sont
quasiment autosuffisant lui mais je
parle du temps tobam à l'époque tu
détestais biocarburants pour faire un
litre de biocarburant il faut utiliser
qu'à 4000 litres d'eau 4000 litres d'eau
de l'eau est rare et c'est déjà très
très très très goûteux sur une planète
que tous les cinq secondes 9 en dessous
dessous de 10 ans meurent de faim brûlés
de la nourriture quelles que soient les
explications l'argumentation apparemment
intelligent et recevable
celle que je viens de dire qu'obama
produit est intolérable
une dernière question vous avez parlé du
faible rendement des cultures en afrique
subsaharienne
est ce que les ong ne constituerait pas
une solution quelle est votre opinion à
ce sujet ah non je suis content les je
suis totalement en compte des ogm je le
demande pour l'information du public des
organismes génétiquement modifiés
génétiquement modifiés parce qu'ils
créent une dépendance terrible du paysan
face à baye et ce sont des questions
marché ce sont des questions de marché
pas des questions techniques
parce qu'il ya des monopoles qui produit
ces semences mais supposons que la f1 au
assume la responsabilité de fournir les
graines il faut seriez techniquement
d'accord avec cela non aujourd'hui les
semences modifiées le roundup et c'est à
face et qui sont qui ont des avantages
ces faits qui sont plus résistants qui
la rentabilité plus élevée et c'est à
ces ogm ces semences génétiquement
modifiées sont preuve tu es donc sont la
propriété garantis et protégés par des
brevets internationaux entre les mains
de dix sociétés multinationales de
dissocier musy nations dont les pluies
dont la plus grande est et monsanto qui
était repris par bayer maintenant et
c'est donc le paysan doit payer chaque
faille pas seulement une fois doit payer
une fois pour
nos gènes pour le pour la semence
physiquement modifié mais chaque année
chaque année quand il recevait ans je
pense doit toujours payer le brevet il
devient l'esclave l'exploiter financiers
des grands trusts et nation de ces
trusts pour concernant les différences
de rendement que vous avez souligné et
ça c'est inadmissible
entre l'europe et l'afrique
subsaharienne elles sont dues non
seulement à l'infrastructure à
l'irrigation et à la mécanisation as
mais aussi aux graines génétiquement
modifiés et je suis totalement d'accord
avec ce que vous dites
l'hôtel je suis il faut je suis content
c'est un argument de marché qui fournit
les graines vous l'avez déclaré au sujet
de la bourse aux aliments en affirmant
qu'on jouait avec les droits
fondamentaux des aliments de base cela
pourrait être interdite dès demain dès
demain on pourrait interdire que ces
graines soient fournis par des
multinationales et ordonné quelle que
soit par des organismes gouvernementaux
ou des institutions internationales
comme les nations unies dans ce cas des
ânes en mettant de côté le problème du
marché
le fait que ce sont des monopoles qui
les fournissait et crée une dépendance
chez les paysans envers ces monopoles ça
s'est mis si ses graines sont fournis
garanties voire fournis gratuitement par
là et fao par exemple techniquement êtes
vous d'accord ou non avec les organismes
génétiquement modifiés
bon là vous êtes en pleine utopie hien
dans la quitter on a quitté le terrain
que la réalité croire que payet là un
jour à renoncer à son brevet est dit
téléphoner à rome à la fao et dire
écoutez on vous offre le brevet t2t le
thème imaginons que cette utopie soit
vrai c'est une utopie comme de dire
qu'on ne fait plus de commerces avec les
aliments de base enfin on est en pleine
utopie
mettons que votre utopique à laquelle je
crois pas du tout se réalise et que leif
à autre
fabrique nico ci commercialise
distribuer les ogm afin d organismes
génétiquement modifiés dans les ti
france aliments il reste pour moi une
res f
je ne peux pas dire oui c'est vrai que
les ogm
le rendement est supérieur c'est vrai
que les ogm ont des multiples avantages
résistance au climat mais on connaît pas
et ce à tous les experts sont d'accord
on ne connaît pas pour l'instant la
conséquence de la santé publique sur la
santé publique
ce qui est arrivé avec la vache folle
par exemple quand on a commencé à
nourrir les vaches charité déchets de
viande ça me suffit ok c'est une
épidémie effroyable
l'action gm peuvent provoquer la même
épidémie il a aucune assurance pour
l'instant est celle oms qui le tient sur
un seul mandat la santé qui le dit qu'on
est à l'abri par suite et sogem l'usa
généralisée des sujets qu'on est à
l'abri de d'épidémie d'effroyables
attaques de
dérégulation de la santé publique par la
consommation généralisée et c'est très
clair donc je continue à dire oh j'aime
non c'est vrai que par exemple en europe
on n'interdit pas les ogm mais on crée
une on a créé et continue d'ailleurs on
crée une on le crée une obligation de
signaler c'est à dire la femme qui va a
fait ses achats dans le supermarché
il faut que les ogm peuvent être vendus
mais soient dessinés comme ogm
donc il prend son risque en connaissance
de cause aux états unis évidement pas du
tout tout est ogm
c'est pour ça que je n'aime pas marre
manger en yole je reste en france et
indien merci d'être venu dans ce
programme
cette conversation était passionnant
grâce à son talent
chaque enfant qui meurt de faim est un
enfant assassiné assassinat l'impératif
moral de l'humanité est d'éliminer toute
forme de pauvreté et éliminer la faim
n'est pas un problème technique pour la
première fois de l'histoire
ce n'est pas un problème lié à des
questions naturelles c'est un problème
de système qui s'excluent mutuellement
photo pi et c'est peut être une utopie
mais l'utopie sert précisément à cela c
est une force historique ce qui ne va
pas là comme elle sert à avancer sans
cesse merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
vous chers amis et rendez vous très
bientôt pour une nouvelle conversation
[Musique]